I had won World Championship ranked
number one in the world
Michael was seen as the Goliath
everybody else was David if I don't win
gold nothing else matters
my coaching I talked about running the
200 meters and 400 meters becoming the
first man to win gold medals in each one
of those event once I announced that I
was going to attempt to make that
history then it just sort of you know
caught everyone's imagination biggest
thing that's going to be acting tonight
Michael Johnson Michael Johnson Michael
John Michael Johnson when you're an
American on home soil you're expected to
deliver the target on my back was about
as big as it could be simply because I'm
the center of the attention here on the
face of this games
I'm the overwhelming favorite but I
always appreciated being in that
position I wanted to be the favorite it
was his statement to say to America I'm
the best in the world
I'm going to do something special and
I'm gonna wear gold shoes because I'm
that confident and hey if anyone could
pull it off it was Michael Johnson I've
been working with Nike they said
basically look you know let's take a
blank sheet of paper and you tell us
what you want and we're going to create
that for you the shoe was a hundred
percent Michael he was pushing us and
really saying this isn't going to be
just your typical normal shoe the idea
was that we were going to create a shoe
that would be the lightest and most
stable track spike ever made he wanted
to feel the track he really wanted to
make sure that every single gram was out
of the shoe that didn't need to be there
then it was a matter of okay then what
is it going to look like the final
prototype was presented to me at one of
my training sessions and it was the gold
shoe but it wasn't gold the initial
intent was was to make it very
mirror-like so you could actually see a
reflection in it my coach was there and
said I don't like it he says I think
that it looks really cool close up but
he says I think that down on the on the
time people understand it's just gonna
look like a silver shoe and as soon as
he said silver shoe I immediately
thought I want my shoe to be gold the
gold shoes was was clearly two things it
was it was a marketing statement by Nike
cause it was cause he was but also it
was a statement for Mike
saying I'm taking on this double and I'm
gonna do it sprinters are like
heavyweight boxers you take your ego you
take your confidence and if you make a
mistake you're on the map if I don't win
gold the fact that I'm wearing gold
shoes will be the least significant of
the issues the 400 meters was first and
you know and I was always aware that you
know that's the race that I don't win
this one then the whole double ideas is
out the window the Olympic final is like
no other race because you understand the
magnitude of it you know that if you get
it wrong for the wait four years four
years a long time to make well a big
history Michael must first
I'll never forget the amount of flash
bulbs that were going on I've never seen
anything
I would be kidding myself and lying to
everybody if I said that any point in
that race that I think that I was going
to be Michael Johnson no and nor did
anybody else in that race I can tell you
that
when I cross the finish line I think I
was just a little bit business as usual
it was very clear to me that Michael was
not in the moment Michael was still very
focused and and and very serious I think
he noticed that I was already focused on
the 200 it must be hard for Michael
because because he had the pressure of
of expectation on him to do the double
and he was already thinking about the
200 meters we're halfway there
this is real the pressure on this man
now is that playing on his mind I was
always aware of the fact that the 200
meters was going to be the most
difficult Jones and then in Lane 4 there
is I never ran the perfect race every
race had something where I didn't
execute it quite as I wish
I got a great reaction to the gun that
day so good that I actually wasn't quite
ready for it and ended up stumbling on
the third step out of the block he was
in such a hurry to get up to his top
speed that his foot almost missed the
ground I probably lost 200 for the
second there but I was able to recover I
was on the outside and as a result
Michael had to sort of come by me to get
past the key was always going to be for
me to get out around the curve and come
off of the bend on to the straight with
a lead
you know when you're on pace and on
track for world record and I could tell
that I was all I saw was the bow shoes
and a blur go by me
that night in Atlanta the world record
on home soil in the bowl shoes it's just
the defining moment of his career I
never thought I was a gamble I thought
what I proved to the world what I knew
that I could do